Elon Musk has declared war on Disney not
only is Gina corano suing over her
termination for her free speech from the
show Mandalorian but Elon Musk has gone
further and said that anyone who's been
fired to hit him up and he will provide
legal support I don't know if this means
they're going class action but it looks
like something akin to what we were
seeing with the markk Cuban Fiasco Mark
Cuban of course is defending the farle
the Dei in the workplace which is
explicitly overtly illegal Elon Musk has
decided to jump into the culture War fry
and he is going after these big
Corporation starting with Disney so
we'll talk a lot about that that's big
Donald Trump has called for a budlight
boycott ceasefire yep nobody cares
they're all tweeting back at his uh at
the post that's being shared from truth
social saying nope doesn't doesn't
matter what Trump says if budlight does
not apologize no one is going to buy
their beer and uh we can talk about
their weird Super Bowl commercial I
guess which is I think I think we broke
the company I have no idea what they're
doing at this point it's just really bad
and then we've got some uh well we got
some good news I guess Tucker Carlson's
interviewing Vladimir Putin that should
that'll be coming out at some point it's
not out yet but that'll be interesting
and then uh uh we've got some troubling
news not that anyone's surprised but
several Republicans defected to join the
Democrats to save mayorcas and his
insane border policies wow this one's
really really incredible as bad as it is
rest assured the Republican party is
only pretending to have your back they
didn't win in 2020 the people didn't
defeat the Democrats and this is exactly
what many of us
predicted I think it's fair that we were
hopeful but look where we are now so
we'll get into all that before we get
set of my friends head over to cast
brew.com to get the best cup of coffee
you'll ever have check out our Alex
Stein's Prime Time grind two times
caffeine but drink responsibly we also
still have our limited edition rise with
abto JR this thing has been uh we did
one run of it so we haven't sold out uh
just yet we launched it on Halloween and
it's because the minimum uh order we
could do was 5,000 and so I figured
we'll do one run but when this is gone
it is gone forever so pick up your
rerise with Roberto Jr Halloween zombie
blend we call it and of course we've got
everyone's favorite appalachin Knights
which apparently it's the only thing
people are buying and we're selling out
of it like crazy and they're buying it
like crazy like thousands of bags so
seriously thank you guys so much and of
course don't forget March 5th at our
cast Brew location it won't be open yet
we will be having a live Show members
only tickets will be made available at
some point soon as we're preparing this
so in one month we will have a live show
it's supposed to be for super Tuesday
but uh I don't know what that's going to
be I guess Nikki Haley is running or
whatever but in Martinsburg West
Virginia if you want to come hang out
live it is not a very big place it's
going to be a small private members only
Club at our Casper building if you want
to support our work and you want to get
access to those tickets you got to be a
member so go to
timcast.net
insults uh it's probably a lot funnier
because we're a lot less serious but
also as a member you can submit
questions and call into the show to talk
to us live on air with our guests so go
to g.com support our work but also smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is Christina erso
thank you so much I'm so grateful to be
here with you guys I am Christina I'm an
independent journalist and content
creator I am currently directing and
producing my first documentary on the
FBI's Governor Whitmer fedna hoax it's
called kidnapp and kill an FBI Terror
plot you can watch the trailer support
the film and learn more about it at K
and K film.com right on thanks for
hanging out should be fun we got Phil
leonti hello everybody my name is Phil
leonti I'm the lead singer of the heavy
metal band All That Remains I'm an
anti-communist and counterrevolutionary
what's up Ian hey not too much man I
worked out earlier I feel good good to
yeah I did some biceps I did some what
are those things where you like are
laying your front on the bench but
you're like pulling it up like this that
is a lat pull God they feel so good man
the lats we were watching these um these
female Seal Team yesterday training
trying to go along the Z L and getting
stuck and I just kept thinking about
their lat strength like you need in
order to get those to really like wiggle
your way on a on a zip line you got to
have strong lats so that was a good
exercise earlier yeah good Stu this was
a members only event there's a it's a
six minute long video where Chile
decided to send a female SWAT team to
this competition I guess for the ls I
don't know what they were thinking and
and you know Lukowski posted it's got
millions of views because these women to
their credit are dang Ling for like a
couple women are holding for for like 3
minutes a 3 minute hold I'm like it's
not bad but they're stuck dangling over
water unable to move it's pretty brutal
but yeah so uh you know build those lats
everyone we got Serge pressing the
buttons yo what's up I'm ready to start
when y'all are yeah all right here's the
big news Gina Carano sues Disney Lucas
film Elon Musk will facilitate others
joining the lawsuits this is uh it's an
eventful day I got to say it's Tuesday
so it's it's news day here what was that
Phil's got speakers blast my bad check
this out actress Gina corano filed the
lawsuit against lucas films and Disney
with the aid of ex-owner Elon Musk she
said uh the actress announced her
lawsuit on in a Tuesday expost after my
20 years of building a career from
scratch and during the regime of former
Disney CEO Bob chapek lucasfilm made
this statement on Twitter terminating me
from the Mandalorian quote Gina corano
is not currently employed by lucasfilm
and there are no plans for her to be in
the future never neveress her social
media posts denigrating People based on
their cultural and religious identities
are abhorent and unacceptable kurano
wrote citing lcas film statement now
here's here's the thing she never said
those things Gina Crono never denigrated
anybody never insulted anybody and she
points this out in a long expost where
she says I never used aggressive
language I shared thought-provoking
quotes pictures memes and I occasionally
occasionally used my words not with
aggression but with respect and the
occasional comedy to keep the mood light
she mentions that in one instance she
said beep bop boop which is in no way
here we go she says so what did I do uh
she says I was I was called a transphobe
for making Droid noises from Star Wars
beep bop boot was obviously directed to
the online bullies and did not in any
way denigrate transgender people but
they did fire a fire her she says a
couple months ago Elon Musk tweeted that
if you had been fired from the platform
from uh fired I think she means four
using the platform X for exercising your
right to free speech he would like to
offer these people legal represent
presentation quite the noble offer but
never in my wildest dreams would I have
thought anyone would take take on my
case against Lucas film in Disney still
I did respond back I think I qualify and
thousands of people agreed but I didn't
expect anything to my surprise a few
months ago I received an email from a
lawyer who had been hired by X to look
into my story and many others turns out
after sending them as much information
as I could I could gather these past few
months my now lawyers and ex believe
wholeheartedly in my case and are moving
forward I would like to express my
deepest gratitude and thank you to Elon
Musk and X for giving me the opport
Unity to bring my case to light as for
me I would like to pick up where I left
off and continue my journey of creating
and participating in storytelling which
is my utmost passion and everything I
worked for it has been difficult to move
forward with the lies and labels Stuck
on Me backed and encouraged by the most
powerful entertainment company in the
world I am grateful someone has come to
my defense in such a powerful way and
look forward to clearing my name it
would appear the reporting I've seen is
that she is seeking to be recast let me
make sure we have that is that uh I
believe that's the uh perhaps not saw a
Hollywood Reporter that should she win
the lawsuit she would want to be recast
uh on the show Mandalorian I don't know
if that if that is exactly what's
happening here but Elon Musk isn't
stopping there he tweeted if you were
discriminated against by Disney or its
subsidiaries ABC ESPN Marvel Etc just
replied to this post to re receive legal
support wow this is going to be big uh I
want to just say as we get into this uh
cuz we also we can read this post put up
from Disney it's good for business there
are a lot of people who are scared to
use Twitter X let's let we'll stop
deadnaming the platform you know we're
almost there they're scared because
they're going to get fired this is Elon
musk's one of his smartest business
moves it's not even about the culture
War I mean I'm sure it is honestly but
I'm sure at the company there are some
business-minded individuals who asked
Elon why sue for people getting fired
from the platform and Elon said look how
many people would be on the platform
verify IED with their profile picture
paying $8 a month if they were confident
they would not be fired for speaking up
a lot of people who use the platform
won't sign up out of fear it will
connect to them and then when they
express their opinions they will lose
their lives we defend them when they get
fired and they'll feel more comfortable
we'll get more users we'll get more
paying subscribers not to mention Elon
Musk probably said think of the
ideological press when we announce we're
doing this every person who opposes this
this anti-free speech is going to sign
up to support us because they know that
that money is helping to fund pushing
back against cancel
culture I mean maybe um I think that I'm
I'm starting to think that he's he's got
a chip on his shoulder now I mean he is
in a position where he's got the federal
government uh you know starting to
really look at him and he's he's getting
pressure from uh the administration and
when the president is you know making
remarks about you saying things like
we're going to look into you that's a
pretty intimidating kind of thing so I
think that there's probably a lot of
personal uh in impulse there you know
but uh I mean maybe he is I don't know
I'm for it what do you guys think yeah
of course I'm for
it main thing I think is that if she
wants to get her job back and get recast
that that would be a very hostile work
environment for her even if they are
forced to do it legally I don't know why
she would want that that's what recast
means someone else right well no I don't
know if it's true he said Hollywood
reporter Tim mentioned me said that she
wanted to get her old role back be
recast on the role yeah I want to make
sure I'm I'm trying to fact check that
because uh I had seen that it's an
interesting demand yes uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah H reporter Crono brings a claim of
wrongful discharge and sex
discrimination she seeks a court order
that would force lucasfilm to recast her
and at least $75,000 plus punitive
damages interesting yeah it's
interesting maybe it wouldn't be a
hostile work I mean she might be friends
with all those yeah and like it was the
producer that she didn't even know that
fired her that no one even knew or
something like that well right right
right somebody made a phone call and
then they came to her and they probably
like Gina we're sorry I mean they're
they're telling us you're out and she
was probably like what the man that's
that's probably crazy and the crazy
thing about it is she's pointed out she
did not we were we read this she didn't
say the things they claimed she said the
big egregious violation was when she
posted uh it was like an image from the
Holocaust and it said do not be tricked
into condemning your neighbors and they
were like she's comp compare comparing
Republic an to Jews in the Holocaust
which she was not she was literally
making a a broad statement of the
government will trick you into being
enemies with your with fellow people yep
and that's like a common occupy leftist
Trope Y where the where the government
corporations want to put the people
against each other yeah I mean not not
to get into the the metaphysical too
deeply or whatever but this this kind of
points to the the argument that the that
the word has power that the that just
having the ability to to articulate
things can make things manifest in
reality what they did was they said look
she said all these anti-semitic things
and even though the content was not
anti-semitic the the point of it was not
anti-semitic and there's no evidence
that it was just people saying look this
connection to you know the the Holocaust
means that she's insensitive means that
she's anti-semitic and it it got enough
people concerned enough where they the
where you know the higher upset Disney
okay you've got to go or they just and
cuz all the estimation is is just is
this worth us defending is it worth us
fighting for I want to I want to just
stress this point that um there are
journalists out there I'll see a news
headline and it'll say something like
Donald Trump uh you know orders drone
strike blah blah blah and I'll be like
wow that's big and then I will click the
story and in the first paragraph it will
start with it was a dark and stormy
night oh God A Midsummer Tuesday scroll
down the end of that paragraph
by the end of the third paragraph tell
you what it's about exactly and we've
all experienced this and I bring this up
because I give you the lawsuit
introduction a short time ago in a
Galaxy not so far away done I skipped to
the end of the paragraph immediately and
see if it's topical I well come on or
was just descriptive defendants made it
clear that only one Orthodoxy in thought
speech and action was acceptable in
their empire and that those who dared to
question or failed to fully no you lost
me oppose Elon Musk I am going full
Democrat I'm a leftist now because of
that I wonder if you let grock write
this thing I have cancer now sounds like
it and it's probably terminal I'm if I
make I can't believe they did that in
the open oh man that sounds like grock
wrote it that's funny I wonder if you
used grock to write that if I got to be
honest like if I was a judge and I I
would be really pissed off I would be so
don't waste my time too no flowy words
give me the N are they are they
expecting that their the judge is going
to be like
a Star Wars nerd or something oh that
was very
clever it is not clever at all so what
else we got
cancer terminal inoperable they say in
her post she expressed her personal
political views opinions beliefs in
retaliation for her exercise of her
speech rights defendant terminated
carano's uh carano's employment and took
other retaliatory actions to limit and
deny her future employment opportunities
including but not limited to making
maliciously false statements about Coran
corano with the intention of damaging
her reputation and thus her ability to
find and retain work I think that's the
important factor here I'm willing to bet
it was an activist at the company who
was like okay we're going to fire her it
doesn't matter if she did anything wrong
and then the statement that went out
saying she made aggressive you know she
made this disparaging comments was to
defame her quite literally because she
never did and I I don't know what lawyer
would sign off on a def a defamatory
statement like that now I think it was
an activist who just went for it maybe
definitely who else
do you think might join in a law like
this I mean are there are there any
other like people we could think of to
get her fired know people that have
beened by Disney yes yes that Elon
ESPN well I mean theoretically I mean I
don't know what anyone that might have
been on
that uh the the series that she was
supposed to be in they were going to
make hered pasc anybody that was
supposed to be in the series they might
be able to be like hey I was supposed to
be a grip on that series or I was
supposed to be this on that series or
they might be able to make a a monetary
claim this is just you know hyp
hypothetical but otherwise I don't know
you know yeah I don't know I suppose you
could argue that
uh yeah these secondary jobs that were
were cut because she was removed from
the show or something I don't know yeah
I don't I don't know that how it will
work out as a class action well let's
take a look at this tweet we have this
tweet from Elon and he says an anonymous
source just sent me this from Disney it
is mandatory institutionalized racism
and sexism it is Disney General
entertainment content inclusion
standards ladies and gentlemen we got a
leak from inside the house showing how
Disney is racist I'd like to give a
shout out to mark cubin this guy his
response to being exposed as a racist
was to claim that he's being attacked by
people who are anti-semitic on on X and
I'm just like that's kind of Mark I got
to be honest that's kind of the Kevin
spacy argument Now Kevin spy gets
accused of rape and then he's like I'm
gay and it's like yes well that may be
but you were accused of rape so uh write
this way to uh jail sir and then we'll
have a trial you know and then I guess
the witnesses like several of the
witnesses or or something happened and
you like went what like Witnesses or
victims died or something like that oh
yeah but I think yeah I think he was
acquitted wasn't he I think so all of
his accusers passed away I believe I
don't think that's true maybe one that
didn't there were a couple I think that
like but but I think he was acquitted
and so if he was like that that that it
is what it is like you know if if that's
the courts find I don't know what else I
can say doesn't mean I completely agree
with it but I'm not going to attack a
guy who who went through the system in
that way that being said back to Mark
cubin who quite literally fights tooth
and nail to be like I want to hire based
on race and he's screaming it and then
people are like dude that's racist and
he's like you hate Jews it's like okay
dude I mean it's not literally what he
did he just immediately started H uh
highlighting all the tweets that were
anti-semitic instead of addressing the
arguments that were against them the the
anti-Semitic Screech is like the most
annoying one right now for me I've had
friends that are like Ian be careful
talking about Israel cuz you be you
people will think you're anti-semitic
I'm like yeah right okay I'm still going
to talk about Israel because I've been
talking a lot about how it got created I
don't want to derail into this we are
not derailing into that so back to
Disney we have this post from Elon Musk
standard a onscreen representation at
least three of the following five areas
need to be met to fulfill standard a
characters 50% or more of regular and
recurring written characters from
underrepresented
groups well in Hollywood that would mean
white people I think right uh 50% or
more of regular recurring actors come
from underrepresented groups secondary
characters meaningful inclusion uh blah
blah blah you get it series premise
integration of underrepresented groups
in overall themes and narratives
episodic storytelling ongoing meaningful
integration of unrepresented groups and
episodic themes blah blah blah St
standard B creative leadership are they
doing
this every single one of these say
underrepresented groups every single one
every single one of these under
represented um okay did they say
underrepresented or is historically
under critical context here we go when
when evaluating whether a group this is
going to be fun is underrepresented it
says anyone involved in hiring decisions
is prohibited from asking candidates and
talent about their actual or perceived
race religion color
orientation sex orientation I believe it
says gender gender identity military or
veteran status age disability or any
other legally protected categories well
okay hold
on if you are a casting director who
needs to find an under represented group
but you can't ask about any of those
things then I think there are only a few
underrepresented groups you can actually
cast and they are going to be atypical
uh for instance uh let's see you want an
underrepresented group under represented
group in your movie but you can't ask
about any of those things but you can't
ask if they're a furry and they're
certainly underrepresented right and
what what other groups are
underrepresented race car drivers okay I
mean I don't see big political action
committees supporting you know race car
drivers bull riders bull riders yeah
going so uh that's the way we can we can
go I do think it's funny they say
military or veteran status yeah like
that and and they're like
it is funny how they're saying you have
to include these things but you can't
ask about
it yeah uh Rona McDaniel out at the uh
at the r we'll get into that one for
sure um yeah look wow there there is
there is
clearly uh the desire to have more
racial awareness which makes people more
racist the reason that people had a
problem with CRT critical race theory
that this is kind of like gone away as a
topic or as a Hot Topic recently because
I well you know topics move along but
the thing that CRT does is it produces
people that have a critical racial
Consciousness they see race before
anything else so the results of CRT is
stuff like the diie stuff the diversity
inclusion inclusion and Equity stuff
that the results are you look at race
first and that all the studies that
you've ever that have ever been done
about this it just makes people more RAC
more racist it makes people want to
divide more it makes people see separate
things it makes people look at at each
at people as as the other it is a
terrible terrible way to look at people
it is illiberal and it is against
everything that our our country is
founded on which is the idea that
individual people are all created
equally and they are to be treated
equally under the law
all of this stuff flies in the face of
that Dei and all of this stuff is not
the continuation of the uh Civil Rights
Movement it is totally antithetical to
anything liberal well that's that the
argument from a lot of people and I
agree is that the Civil Rights Act
created the pathway for all of this that
that's an argument that could be made
because technically you shouldn't have
any of the stuff that applies to the
private sector in the in the Civil
Rights Act the about you know you not
you can't H you can't discriminate on
based on race or anything technically
that stuff shouldn't apply to the
private sector if you want to make those
kind of arguments in the in the public
sector in the government and stuff like
that you can make an argument but
technically as long as you have the
freedom to associate you should be able
to say I don't want to be around those
people but once the government starts
getting involved in that then that's
setting the precedent that the
government has the right to get involved
in that shouldn't wonder I wonder what
the statute of limitations is on this
because I don't know if it matters
considering the company I worked for
doesn't exist anymore but it wasn't ABC
News uh joint venture fusion and they
discriminated against Me based on my
race that was they had a they had a
thing called the black and brown Forum
where Jesus what yeah it's something
that I think they still do it and they
were interview they interview like
Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders and I
was one of their like Star Talent
reporters and when they had the event I
wasn't I wasn't made a I I knew it was
going on and I didn't hear anything and
I was like I'm just going to do my thing
like I'm not somebody who really
complains when the event happened they
brought in like three of the top talent
they had for the company fusion and then
they cast a black guy who was from New
York who was like a comedian and
well-known and I didn't I'm like look
I'm not I'm not I don't care like you
can do whatever you want it's your
company I literally don't care I'm doing
my thing I'm getting paid however when
all of this stuff started coming up and
I was like because the guys who run the
company were not woke they didn't know
or care they were just like I don't know
this is what we're told the marketing
people and the young people but I was
explicitly told by the president of the
company that I look too white to be to
be a part of that program and I'm like
man you had a chance to get like a mixed
race Asian guy in the program this6 2016
November 19 2015 is when Fusion
announced they were going to broadcast
with the Iowa brown and black
presidential Forum there you go and I
was like I come from a mixed race family
I think I was like what and you know and
I I wonder I mean maybe it's too late I
don't know if I would care all that much
to be involved but I do kind of feel
like the reason I bring it up is like
it's it's this is too way too long ago
it's like a decade ago I are better left
lying
well I just think it's probably tooo
long ago but I can at least say this
this is a company that was half-owned by
ABC News and they they have been doing
this for a long time El's looking for
people ABC is a subsidiary of Disney
elon's looking for people to join in
maybe that's what I'm saying it's it's
it's it's been it's been uh nine years
so actually it's been eight years
because it's only a few months after
November when they did it but at the
very least I don't think I would be
involved in any way I want to make sure
it is known I experienced this it
literally happened the company was
insanely racist and sexist it was it was
insane how racist they were there was a
there was one instance where the news
team was going over a story about Ghost
in the Shell uh this is when Scarlett
Johansson was going to be playing uh the
major the main character from Ghost in
the Shell and they were like why is a
white woman playing a Japanese woman and
I said actually she's a robot and
actually it's really it's transhumanist
a core concept of Ghost in the Shell is
being able to transfer to different
bodies different sexes different races
and they're like nah they're just racist
so we're going to call it racist instead
like it had to be viewed through that
lens no matter what and I'm like okay
yeah right and uh I will say this Elon
please uh look into this the
editor-in-chief Alexis Madrigal had a
Twitter Banner at the time that said
down with
whiteness yeah and this stuff has been a
Black Fist this stuff has been been
being churned out of uh
colleges every year for at least a
decade now that means 10 years of
graduating classes from all over the
country people that have this kind of
ideology built in have been getting jobs
or maybe they haven't been getting jobs
but at least some of them have been
getting jobs in Human Resources
departments all over the country this is
this is such a massive it was a pro
massive problem a decade ago and now
it's reached the point where it is
likely that the United States will not
be will not get out of this the same and
be the same country we've got to
acknowledge were you going say something
just that Yuri basmanov said what it was
one generation was all you needed to
demoralize and then you could
destabilize the country and you're
saying like 10 years so another five
years yeah I don't know and people are
still arguing as if this is even
happening yeah it like we're we're all
born equal legally equal but we're not
all the same and we all come from
different nutrition backgrounds and if
our parents were poor they didn't have
access to nutrition maybe their brains
weren't as developed so their child's
brains weren't as developed and then if
I come from poverty maybe I'll be poor
too and I won't have good brain matter
my kids won't either so there's like
then when you you're like you throw
these kids in school and you're like
learn math the kids that don't have the
brain matter that come from poverty
struggle because they don't have the
mental capacity but that doesn't mean
you take those kids and you shove them
into CEO positions just so that you have
enough color like the same color or the
right color like you've also got to let
people flounder like it's the sad nature
of reality of people come from suffering
they've got to either figure it out for
themsel I mean at least that's seems to
be the least worst Way Forward is to let
people do it on their own instead of
force feed and force the system
into but I mean I'm totally down with
like the the the the descendants of
slaves in the United States had like
they come from generational poverty and
lack of nutrition not everybody but some
of those families do so that that's a
real problem but I don't think forcing
them into positions of power is the
right way to solve for order to give
them money you know you got to feed them
you know you could argue like healthy
food but that would be like Society wide
that wouldn't just be you wouldn't just
want to Target little communities with
with good nutrition you could maybe
potentially you know food stamps tend to
get people Pepsi I've seen that you can
buy pepsy with food stamps that's insane
to me agree there's all kinds of of
problems with like entitlement programs
and stuff like that but the fundamental
thing that that you're talking about is
is whether or not people have you know
the the the ability to you know provide
sustenance for themselves and I don't
know that there's a significant amount
of hunger in the United States to the
point where it's affecting whether or
not people like develop properly like I
get that happens in like North Korea
like you get people that are so
malnutrition so malnourished they they
don't you know they're two inches
shorter than people in South Korea or
whatever but I don't know if that's
happening in the US is it well I I
imagine after like 1860s it was people
were pretty poor and the depression 7
million people died during the Great
Depression well I mean that that kind of
stuff you're talking about is is stuff
that would happen now to people born now
though right and now we're it's not that
they don't have food it's that they
don't have nutrition like a lot of the
preservatives and stuff sold in the
cheap food at the store is like it
actually makes them obese yes which is
also that's not feeding the brain
properly in my opinion like giving it's
creating another struggle cuz like obese
I don't know if obesity is generational
do obese parents tend to give birth to
children that are prone to obesity they
don't give birth to them but obesity is
behavior based if you don't move enough
and you don't
exercise the food that they get taught
to to eat when their kids as well like
if they don't have the you know the
people telling them how to cook and what
they should be cooking and then they'll
probably just eat prepackage food their
entire life and that does happen all the
time and then they raise their kids like
that and then those habits you develop
at a really young age you carry them
forward with you and then you teach your
kids those bad habits unless you break
that
cycle well I suppose you know you want
reparations you got to teach people to
break that cycle and first they got to
even know what that cycle is which
requires some
education let's jump to the big breaking
news Ron McDaniel RNC chairwoman plans
to step down Donald Trump is Trump is
likely to back an election denier
Michael Watley the that of the North
Carolina GOP to replace her so
apparently uh Trump got on the phone
with her and then people were expecting
something to happen and then like one of
her I think her Chief of Staff or some
you know one of her top staff members
resigned and and now the New York Times
reporting she is uh uh planning to
resign I think there's actually look
there's been a Revolt in the Republican
party over her failure AB abject failure
and uh this is great this is absolutely
fantastic news this is we are we are
excising the Old Guard establishment
neocon types and unip party garbage from
the RNC did you guys know that I I
believe someone search for this I heard
that the Democrats have raised three
times what the RNC has raised yeah i' I
don't know what I don't know if it's
three times but I've heard that it's a
significantly larger amount of money
because no one's going to give them
money so long as Ron McDaniel is is is
his position I hope you're right and
thank I'm very very happy to hear that
Rona McDaniel is out you cannot fail as
as regularly as she did and expect to
keep your job and I mean it just it's
ridiculous that she's that she's stuck
around the fact like the fact that she
made it it after Trump uh you know lost
in 2020 like she should have been gone
then yeah because in my opinion the
whole the reason that that the reason
that Trump lost was because of the RNC
not being prepared with actual on the
ground stuff to compete with the
Democrats the way they were clearly you
know ballot harvesting and stuff and I
don't care that people are going to sit
there and make excuses for the
Republicans I don't care about the
excuses I don't care care why you lost
you lost you get fired for that get out
of here RNC reported its worst
fundraising year since 2013 wow she's a
joke they raised 87 million and they
started 2024 with just over 8 million in
cash now now hold on what look up
turning point USA can we can we look up
their numbers Let's uh let me do a quick
search yeah how much how much money has
she mismanaged though and squandered
like how much money did she start out
with it was millions of dollars that she
had that she did nothing with that she
completely
squandered how much has the RNC
raised since do we know the
RNC or you're looking for Turning Point
how much is turning point raised RNC so
we can we can compare 87 million 87
million that's a lot more that uh that's
in 2023 a lot more than I think tpusa
raises but the interesting thing is when
you look at we when we were at Turning
Point uh uh mfest a lot of people are
saying like this is basically replacing
the RNC I
that's a good point that's the vibe I
got while I was there it just felt like
if there's going to be what you would
call a Republican National Convention
that's what the Turning Point feels like
and Des santis didn't go that was crazy
I don't know that was real I like as
Governor I mean now that he's not
running anymore he's like he's like a
badass again yeah it's not crazy but he
he's got no Charisma I'm sorry no but I
mean like now that he's not running for
president all of a sudden he's just like
when he said Deport ilhan Omar I was
like oh
what where was this guy exactly jez
where's he been for reference the DNC
seems to have raised 1440 million to the
rnc's 87 million yeah they they
embarrassing that that's more with Joe
Biden says Allied groups uh so it might
be just more than just DN wow dude the
RNC entered 2024 with eight with only $8
million that's nuts that's
insane raised million in the first month
something like that that's nuts man how
much they ra they entered the year with
8 million in cash and now they've got
how much 87 I don't think this article
has their total uh rate okay here we go
they raised 87.2 million in 2023 ending
the year with 8 million left in the bank
wow wow the DNC raised 119 million with
21 million cash on hand and then I'm not
finding turning points numbers exactly
but uh their revenue of 2022 was 55
million that was their revenue 55
million
they're starting to rep this is what I
was wondering they're starting to
replace the RNC why would anyone donate
to the RNC at all it used to be that
like Hey we're going to we're going to
support the Republican party and we're
going to support their candidates and
then when you donate they can donate
that money to one of the candidates nah
best thing they could do is make Charlie
Kirk the head of the RNC or we just I
don't know if you take it at this point
yeah I mean it is good that Ron McDaniel
is out but I got I got to be honest I
don't care for the Republican
establishment and I think it's true many
Trump supporters felt the same way
that's why they started using the lion
instead of the uh what the the elephant
right GOP elephant no I didn't know that
yeah they start using a lion for Trump
cuz like it's a different party yeah I
think it's fairly obvious in 2016 and
it's it's it's the Ron Paul generation
the the Ron Paul populace types went Mis
caucus libertarian or they or they went
not all of them some of them went Trump
some of and some of the the misus guys
are actually uh speak positively of
Trump's foreign policy despite it not
being perfect but then you get the
Bernie Sanders progressives and there
was an attempted uh outing of the of the
leadership in the Democrat and
Republican parties in
2016 Donald Trump succeeded Bernie
Sanders failed you want to know you want
to know why that happened Place Bernie
Sanders next to Donald Trump there's
your answer no question that was the
best the progressive left could muster
up for a populist Revolt in the
Democratic party yeah Bernie's going to
stand outside the nor knocking going
excuse me can I please come in and
Donald Trump just hires a bunch of guys
with battering rams and he walks and
it's my time now we're taking it and
that's what he did
and uh they desperately need they
desperately for their cause need to stop
him but uh they can't here we go with
the outting of Ron McDaniel finally holy
crap did you say they mentioned a guy
they want to put in as the head of the
RNC already they've already got
a yeah Michael Watley they say he's an
election denier I didn't realize he was
a Democrat who thought Trump was a
Russian agent oh oh oh they're saying he
has questions about potential voter
fraud yeah I mean you know I I I get it
um uh election wait what doj arrests New
Jersey Democrat for mail and ballot
fraud uh oh if I if I agree with the doj
am I an election denier now I don't want
to be an election denier guys man I
can't believe it took this long to get
rid of Ronald McDaniel it's almost too
little too late to be honest well well I
mean I would disagree just because of
the fact that it's still you know it's
February there's there's still a lot of
time a lot of time most most elections
you don't have such a clear idea of who
the nominee is going to be this early
usually it's not until at least April
you know you know until you you know
people really kind of shake out so she
might whoever comes in might be able to
do some some good hopefully I I kind of
think it's fair to assume this year will
be the weirdest thing you've ever seen I
know we joke about Ben Shapiro rapping
like aha it's 2024 and Ben Shapiro is
the biggest rapper in the world blah
blah blah and like it's a joke no it's
not really that big a deal like there's
a lot of cultural things that have
happened you know the fjb song hitting
number one we obviously have some
cultural influence on our side I'm
talking about we we have a lot of
expectations of what's going to happen
but I'm saying like dude if aliens came
down and just abducted Nikki Haley in
the middle of like a speech I would just
not be surprised at all I'm half kidding
you like maybe not aliens but I'm just
saying right now we expect Trump to be
the nominee I honestly have no idea I I
I I i' put my Bet On It place my chips
on that Donald Trump's going to be the
nominee but I don't know man I mean vake
I think made a good point about they
will stop at nothing yeah we we
literally have no idea and and I'm I'm
here's what I'm worried about a Black
Swan event happening in the next few
months there's no way to predict it
these things happen you have no idea
yeah my worst fear well no actually this
is just one of my fears is a power out
is like a grid down water down situation
for Two Plus weeks
uh something that would cause water down
if the water grid goes out then disease
gets really can get really nasty they
reporting that the houthis may cut
undersea cables disrupting International
Communications wow when I I was doing
this war gaming in my head like what's
the worst and I'm thinking okay they
they really want to create like a world
order but they want order they don't
want World chaos they want order so
they're not going to knock out power
grids and things like I don't think that
that's the aim is to destroy and corrupt
I think the idea is to peacefully take
control so I don't know I don't depends
on if if you believe that they that
there is actually a plan to uh decrease
population why not well they I know
there's a plan that they want to slow
the growth of the population I mean I
think that there's a plan they want to
slow the growth I don't know if they
actually want to go decrease the total
or if they just want to slow the growth
of the total I'm not sure exactly I I I
I think we've got probably a normaly
bias yeah but not an optimism bias I
think many of us actually are concerned
about what's going to happen this year
but you know I've been thinking about
this every day I wake up I got routine
you know what I mean we come in I sit
down I got my little spin drift right
here and we got our Bill Tong and we do
the show every day and I wake up in the
morning and I read the news every day
and part of me is thinking like I kind
of feel like it is reasonable to expect
that at some point this year something
will happen that will completely disrupt
our ability to have some kind of routine
we saw that with Co that shattered
everything y it is 2024 it is four years
on they do not want Trump to win by any
means necessary so I kind of just feel
like Black Swan event I don't know what
it's going to be yeah I don't know man I
don't know either I I there's a
significant part of me that doesn't
believe that Donald Trump will be you
know the president in
2025 no matter what happens of the Neo
Confederacy he will be the union that's
another question I mean I that's I don't
I don't I don't want to talk about that
but like I I just don't think that that
I don't think that the the the
establishment will allow it I I think
that they're going to come up with some
kind of excuse whether it be whether it
be something that actually happens in on
Election Day or not you know we we
already saw that uh they said he has no
immunity yeah yeah so I'm I'm I'm game
man uh let's arrest Barack Obama stat
that's something you know there was I
think it was Daryl Isa I retweeted
something today just a little while ago
I think it was Daryl Isa that was making
illusion to that exact thing that if it
is that if the case is that Donald Trump
does not have immunity than Barack Obama
doesn't either and of course and so so
all we need is some uh Republican in uh
uh I don't know law enforcement anywhere
with some balls to initiate the criminal
proceedings against Barack Obama for the
extrajudicial assassination of anoir
alaki and his son Abdul Raman alaki yep
but you know um Republicans are cowards
oh man that's not fair dude weak cowards
that's not that's still not fair it is
not fair to call Republic cuz you're
insulting weak cowards uh the
Republicans are worse than that they are
like gimps unleashes for the Democrats
and don't take my word for it we have
this story from the post millennial
house fails to impeach DHS secretary
Alejandro mayoras four Republicans
defected to join the Democrats
in supporting what everyone in the
country is now calling an invasion you
see Al Sharpton called it an invasion y
yes even Democrats are saying this
margorie Taylor green said it's not over
there's a there was a motion to recommit
they could bring up articles next week
Laura lummer tweets the House GOP just
failed to impeach DHS secretary
Alejandra mayorcas even when they gave
the majority when they have the majority
Republicans always fail to deliver these
are the Republican traders who voted no
they should all be removed from Congress
they are essentially Democrats Ken buck
doesn't give a damn because he's
retiring selfish POS Tom mlto of
California Ken Buck of Colorado Mike
Gallagher of Wisconsin and Blake Moore
of Utah all those guys like to get
kicked in the nuts I want to stress this
right now to each and every one of you
make it heard to the best you can if
there's anything we can do on this show
I'll tell you I am a guy who complains
to a camera for a living but if there's
anything I can do it is to tell all of
you listening to make sure you tell
everyone you know never donate another
Penny to anything related to mcclint Ken
Buck Gallagher Blake Moore never
contribute in any way and if you can you
live in their districts campaign against
them run against them and stop giving
money to the RNC until they come out
apologize for this replace Ron McDaniel
which they're doing right now but
they're going to get in somebody else
and even then I'm not even convinced I
got to be honest I'm not even convinced
the RNC deserves a single penny no
matter who they put in place if there's
one thing we can do right now let's make
sure that when rep mlto gets on that
phone looking for donors they tell him
to screw off he he has betrayed the
American people and they hang up on him
if you live in California's Fifth
District call him and say you have
betrayed us and do everything you can to
make sure these people never never get
reelected name and shame them I like
that they should all be shamed um I
think that nobody feels like they have
political representation here like
Democrats or Republicans I think on both
sides people feel like they're not
represented and the only people that are
are corporations the corporate donors
have representation but regular people
don't so uh I I'll play for you the clip
here this is uh it's frustrating but
here you
go on this vote the Y's are 214 and the
Nays are 216 the resolution is not
adopted oh somebody got there's some
back room stuff going on there exactly
yep take a look at that wow four
Republicans oh decided to be like let's
be Democrats I I I'm just I'm so I'm so
over it man it doesn't surprise me the
States they're from California Colorado
Wisconsin Utah one even though no that
all makes sense yeah even though some
people think that Utah is is you know no
conservative it is not is not nearly as
conservative as as yeah I was going to
say but you can actually search can can
for 10 years it's definitely not
everyone has that perception because of
like the LDS church but it's not the
case this this right here is the kind of
thing that I I'm I'm going to say it
civil war no a failed impeachment inquir
is not this look this is good that
they're actually doing this nope when
people vote and the Republicans get in
in
2022 and they say now that we have
Congress we're going to make some
changes and they
don't people just are you're going to
generate a massive loss of confidence in
the system yeah right people feel like
they have to take things into their own
hands because they feel like nobody
listens to them nobody represents them
and they do this year after year after
year where they give someone a chance
and they think finally we'll get
something done for us and it never
happens and I think it makes people very
frustrated but I almost feel like they
do it on purpose you know like they're
paid to lose and I feel part of it is
like a humiliation ritual for us all you
know like they're publicly humiliating
us they know that like 90% of the
country wants reasonable border control
and Border policy but this is what we
get and now it's happened is you've got
Al Sharpton and other Democrat
personality saying why are Republicans
obstructing our attempts to solve the
Border crisis that makes me it's really
frustrating and then the Republicans do
exactly what they say
oh God Sharpton called an invasion but
then thought that the Republicans were
blocking yes the attempt to stop it he
said every day we see an invasion of
immigrants On the Border we got to call
these Republicans and hold them
accountable for what they're doing to
get them to sign that open border bill
that they wanted to do that's what they
do so they got sharp that's the name of
the
game and and people are are are going to
buy it and there there are a lot of
people that are out on like Twitter and
and in influencers that are just out
there just to spread the the essentially
the the uh official narrative and
they're out there saying you know doing
the whole blame the Republicans it's the
Republicans you need this bill and blah
blah blah blah blah you don't need any
of that I know that there are people out
there that are saying oh you know that
they need to have a a bill you need to
have some kind of new legislation etc
etc and that that's not true at all
that's not it and the reason that you
know it's not true is because in
emergencies the government does all
kinds of crazy they did the Berlin
airlift if they can do the
Berlin airlift the Berlin airlift was
literally they were Landing beef like
planes in Berlin every like 15 or 30
seconds to supply the food because to
supply food and all the the things that
Berlin needed because the Russians shut
off access with the ground so the US uh
what's it called uh UK and I forget who
else they were literally flying beef or
planes into into Berlin
for everything they needed fuel food
everything because you couldn't get
there on post World War II yeah this is
right after World War II this this is
when the Iron Curtain was going up so if
they can do the Berlin airlift right if
they can manage to do that if they can
make the nuclear bomb they can figure
out the Border without without new
legislation I don't I don't buy for a
second that they can't it's just that
they lack the will they refuse to and
they refuse to because it's politically
useful it's not lack the will their
Wills are Ironclad brother their will is
for open border and they are doing
everything in the power to maintain it
and manipulate the public and destroy
this country I am actually really
impressed with their willpower to
maintain a destructive open Border in
the face of their own constituents
screaming at them to shut it down I mean
you've got Democrats in Democrat
stronghold screaming about the
immigration crisis and these Republicans
are like I'm going to stand strong and
work for the Democrats wow unbelievable
I am impressed by your by your s I'm
impressed by their sacrifice so let it
be said to those uh uh those four
members of the uh I guess can they're
now honorable Democrats I hope they
never see another penny in Don even
those guys like all those Dem people in
the Democratic party that voted not to
impeach the guy I mean is the guy he
seems like he's doing a piss poor job of
protecting the Border by letting all
these millions of people across the
border he is facilitating yeah so all
these people that are not on board like
the impeachment sounds rational at least
in impeachment inquiry like like why is
he not why is he falling short going on
that's why they had the vote they they
did the inquiry to see you know if
they're going to actually should try to
impeach him oh yeah Cory Mills was
talking about doing this the last time
he was on the show and I thought I mean
it's worst case scenario he with an
impeachment is they find him not guilty
and look if you if you get an
impeachment though then that's that's a
signing blame that means that an
indictment it's not it's not it's an
indictment so yeah but what I'm saying
is if if he if he does then that's if if
the Democrats if any of the Democrats or
whatever were to vote for the
impeachment that's saying yes we did
something wrong that's an admission of
guilt and that's what they're trying to
avoid it's just the appearance of doing
anything wrong they're just it's total
denial
time we vote out every single one of the
Republican incumbents love that all of
them I will take a ham sandwich at this
point just to punish these people for
being as bad as they are now now maybe I
think it's fair if we assess those who
are good because Matt Gates definitely
should stay uh in terms of the Senate
Rand Paul always will will have my vote
Thomas Massie as much as I disagree with
him on a lot of things I still respect
him would like to see him stay as well
you know and I think there's a lot uh
many of us disagree with Massi on but
he's also very good on many other things
and he's a nice guy I'll take it I think
he's being honest but I disagree with
some of his positions there are way too
many people who are willing to like
every single every single one who voted
to remove Santos don't know don't care
yeah that that right like the fact that
Santos is gone has only made this more
likely yep I know and I like him now I
don't why I just I think he's great he
didn't he did not lie any more than any
other politician it was just the way
that he lied and what he lied about
that's right they're all Crooks you know
he just got caught y we don't even know
that he got caught that's
true he there was no he never actually
got found guilty of anything they just
booted him because he was accused so all
the Republicans who voted rid of them
these the they got to go they got to be
they got to be ousted someone else has
got to move in Democrats will line up
linking arms to burn down police
stations and Republicans are like well
on procedure we can't impeach the man
who's destroying our barter Democrats
are so good at falling in line they will
tell you that a man is a woman with a
straight
face all right well it feels like they
were falling in line Donald Trump we
can't let the thing happen you've got to
protect this guy we've got to jump to
the next big story Donald Trump has made
a very important statement pertaining to
very serious issues here in the United
States and that is he wants us to drink
Bud
Light Donald Trump posted the Bud Light
ad was a mistake of epic proportions and
for that a very big price was paid but
anheiser bush is not a woke company but
I can give you plenty of that are and
building a list and might just release
it for the world to see why not the
radical left does it viciously to
well-run conservative companies and
people okay I don't understand that very
nasty but it's the way they play the
game on the other hand anzer Bush spent
$700 million a year with our great
Farmers employ 65,000 Americans of which
1500 are veterans and is a founding
corporate partner of folds of Honor
which provides scholarships for families
of Fallen servicemen and women they have
raised over $30 million and given 44,000
scholarships anheiser bush is a great
American brand that perhaps deserves a
second chance what do you think perhaps
instead we should be going after those
companies that are looking to destroy
America well I will there good sir
Donald Trump as much as I'm looking
forward to voting for you you are a far
far from perfect candidate and eard Bush
is not an American company thank you and
have a nice
day it's a Belgian company it's owned by
inbev right it's not an American company
and I can respect his View and I think
the reason he's doing it is anheiser
Bush probably does give a lot of money
and so a lot of politicians are like we
need the money coming from anzer Bush
and now Donald Trump has come out and
said it is time to end the boycott it's
time to give in to the global fascism
what say you panel all in favor of
ending the budlight boycott so sayith
Donald Trump I so don't even care
because I don't drink beer yeah if if I
was in a situation and someone handed me
a beer and it was Bud Light I would
drink it I'm not going to buy the stuff
that's my that's where I'm at so uh
unless I didn't want to drink it then I
wouldn't many people have responded
directly to the post saying no not until
there's an apology and I I I 100% agree
Fair I actually so I don't know if you
guys saw the Super Bowl ad they made
it's isn't it really stupid that they're
putting they put Super Bowl ads out
before the Super Bowl now yeah that was
what I was thinking what I think we
broke blood light I think we broke them
I think there's like a guy sitting in
like the marketing department his
underwear smoking cigarettes with like
bags under his eyes rocking back and
forth I want to smoke cigarettes
refreshing his feet over and over and
over yeah just so so basically they do
they they they did this ad campaign with
u Miles Teller and some women I don't
know who she is and she's on hold and
he's like dancing towards her with two
cans of Bud Light and then they dance
together and then laugh and drink Bud
Light in the living room at like 9:00 in
the morning or something I don't know I
don't know what time it's supposed to be
in the commercial but it's stupid anyway
they're both not at work so I'm assuming
it's maybe late but uh it's cringe and
everyone made fun of them for it few
months later they launched the Dylan
milany thing and nuke their own company
trying to recover they launched a
partnership with Harley-Davidson we're
manly beer we drive motorcycles and
everyone made fun of them and then I
can't remember who it was is uh well
they got made fun of then they partnered
with UFC and uh everyone made fun of
them Sean Strickland came out said I'm
gonna fix you and and many people
started saying Hey look it's fine Joe
Rogan was like who cares the beer is
fine then they sponsored Shane Gillis
and Shane Gillis is is not a woke
comedian they uh I don't know what
capacity they're working with him but he
got cancelled for I think he was doing
like an Asian accent and still people
are like I don't know he got canceled
for doing an Asian accent that's what it
was right it was an asent it an asent
accent on a podcast like that's he was
on Satur live and then someone found an
old video of this is why this is why
it's so clearly like just it's about an
attack Vector because like the guys in
South Park have been doing Asian accents
for the entire time that they've had
shitty walk you know that's right or
City Walk you know and so uh budlight
made a commercial now for the Super Bowl
and it's the budlight genie
and it is it is it's it's it's like
someone just put a bunch of random words
in a Ai and it spat out it's AI
generated commercial I think they were
just like I don't know CH GPT write a
commercial for us and they're like okay
a guy opens a fridge and he grabs a Bud
Light then the genie pops out he wishes
for heavy metal hair a woman wishes for
uh wealthy clothing another guy wishes
for one big arm then they wish to be at
a party then post Malone is there then a
T-Rex comes in post Malone takes credit
for it then they wish everybody has Bud
Light and the genie tries dancing and
then they're like the Bud Light Genie
and then it's over oh God that sounds
horrible sound so bizarre I don't know
who we broke them I like I like post
Malone he's cool but we we I'm like we
broke them like they don't know what to
do at all and they're like H post balone
dinosaurs
genies and then and then Donald Trump
the trump card Bud Light somehow got
Donald Trump to post please please drink
Bud Light I hope he at least got paid
for this then maybe he knows somebody
company or he just saw that because it
is about money anheiser Bush does have a
a factory in the United States at least
one I think the headquarters it's a
subsidiary of a Belgian company so
technically it's Belgian but it is
entrenched in the United States hires
Americans and that's what Trump's
concerned with is those people but
that's like a shortterm thing you can't
if you always trying to fix the people
around you but you're not looking at the
bigger picture of what's causing the
problem you might end up just feeding
into the greater problem let's do a poll
smash the like button if you think we
should not buy budlight until they
apologize I'm smash I know that like the
like button's gonna the like count is
going to Skyrocket because because of
that that's kind of the point but uh I
would actually agree my I think with
this move and we've got the upcoming uh
strike that's going to happen which is
going to just decimate Bud Light I think
that's why Trump they tapped the big
guns they like Trump we need you to come
out I wonder how much they pledged I
mean look right if Donald Trump is
coming out in defense of budlight
they've basically aligned themselves
more than any company could align
themselves so Bud Light just publicly
declare you're committing a billion
dollar to Donald Trump's re-election in
some capacity I'll tell you this how
about you run a commercial apologizing
saying ANZ Bush loves America made a
terrible mistake and is deeply
apologetic for the the insult and the
offense and then Donald Trump walks in
the frame and says and that's why I
drink Bud Light and cracks One open then
we go buy some it's just like please
accept my apologies so that our Global
corporations can take you over like
no thanks I'm done I I learned my lesson
it's like a bad relationship I'm never
going back I've already made my move you
know why doesn't Donald Trump post post
Donald Trump should come out and be like
everyone go by conservative dad's Ultra
right right hm why aren't we building
the parallel economy up yeah that's a
question I asked myself whenever uh
people are like why are you not voting
for Donald Trump I got come the
questions like why is he not tapped into
what we what's really going on why is he
like still corporate why is he still
playing with the the big money guys and
cuz he's a million cuz he's a
millionaire well so because he's a
million years old here's a question for
everybody listening uh it seems like a
general sentiment in response to Trump
is if they apologize that's all they
have to do apologize
for those that drink beer and uh for
those that drink a lot of it CU Bud
light's not you know I'm basically
trying to say like you know if you're
going to the bar with your friends I'm
I'm not going to I wouldn't order Bud
Light ever even before the boy Yingling
okay if if we're going to get a beer
it's going to be a Yingling maybe I had
one of those with Sheamus over the last
week it was nice they're great Sheamus
and uh and and you know if if if they
only had like your traditional Fair Blue
Moon perhaps but for those that you know
drink a lot and you've got something
lighter would you consider drinking bud
like if they issued a public statement
let's say they tweeted out a card and it
just said we are sincerely apologetic
for having sponsored Dylan mulany we
understand it was offensive we we deeply
apologize to those who are offended by
it and we will absolutely work to get
your C your your your to you know your
to bring customers back would that be
enough for you guys one in the chat if
yes two if you will never drink Bud
Light No Matter
What well I'll answer that no I would
not they want their young drinkers they
want to get their young drinkers they
want to get those young people hooked on
their drinks their alcohol drinks I'm
not into it but like apologizing for
having done that no not good enough like
the Nazis apologized to get you on their
team before World War II was over I
don't think Weir budlight sponsoring
Dylan M Hey Thomas Jefferson said that
uh central banks are more dangerous than
standing armies and a lot of this stuff
is Corporate oh looks like a mixed bag
we got both of those looks like people
are it's a mix between ones and two some
people are saying they're never going to
drink it again two is never going to
drink it again right yeah yeah there's
W everyone's just basically saying no
never again a lot of twos wow L of TW
even with an apology it's no good yeah
but you know the the chat here on
YouTube it is definitely uh it's it's
got a negative bent on it yeah it's got
we're influencing it in real time
negative B on it they they generally are
kind of like no people what did Luke say
did you say Luke Luke said he wasn't
going to do it okay hold on what if what
if they apologize with a video from
James Lindsay which opens with him
saying uh him standing next to the CEO
of inbev apologizing for having
sponsored Dyan mlan explicitly saying
they truly did not understand the nature
of gender ideology and these far-left
Fringe policies and how they were
affecting the business now that they see
how wrong it was they would like to give
the next 20 minutes of their airtime to
James Lindsay to explain the problem of
Marxism cultural Marxism far-left gender
ideology and racial ideologies in our
schools in universities in our politics
take it away James would you then buy a
Bud Light if that was if the Super Bowl
like Super Bowl yeah I would because I
know James Lindsay would be like a
complete jerk for like the first five he
be so Savage in that first five minutes
on that I'm trying to not swear too I
was just trying to come up with like
what's the antithesis of Dylan M like
what is the opposite of what you could
do probably that James Lindsay giving a
lecture on the problems of these woke it
would be the opposite would be like a
real woman giving a leure opposite
actual vagina just just just like a a
busty woman being like we're so
sorry had sex with real man before you
know very different normally my my
victory condition is if they sell the
company's the one though if they were to
sell the anheiser bush back to an
American owner i' then I'd consider
working buying from their company again
but I what you're saying like if they
did do that with James Lindsay and they
they did like a campaign to educate
people I'd be open to that is inev own
it's traded on the stock market AB inbev
yeah I think it's a public it's traded
on the stock market it's not really an
American or foreign company I mean who
the owners are the whoever owns the
stock you know yeah their headquarters
is in Belgium it's in laon Belgium um
but I mean they sell that they sell
things all over the world they they stop
being like nowadays it is really true
that there are you know transnational
you know companies that actually
transcend Nation like Japanese car
producers are a huge example of that
like Toyota Etc all those companies most
of are made te Tuesday for those who
celebrate Let's uh let's jump to the
story from cnr.com Tucker Carlson
confirms interview with Vladimir Putin
it's our job our duty is to inform
people and apparently he now wants to
interview zalinsky as well a lot of
speculation because Tucker Carlson was
seen uh flying to Moscow and uh of
course everybody thought this is going
to be the interview apparently he was
advised by the US government not to do
it but uh ladies and gentlemen I really
I look at this stuff and I'm like the
machine is
failing that's just it they can't stop
Tucker they try to stop him but the
internet has given people an opportunity
to build up their own platforms with
their own voices and allow us to
actually communicate in ways that could
end War because I think when people hear
what Putin has to say if Tucker Carlson
does this right and he can do it wrong
if he does it right I think it can
actually help simber down tensions that
are pushing us towards a World War III
scenario I like it yeah hopefully my
concern is that if Tucker doesn't ask
hard questions it will be viewed as as a
puff
piece yeah yeah and people are going to
make that argument regardless yeah the
Russia Russia Russia but there are
there's an American journalist in
detained in Russia currently yes yeah do
do we know his name is is it uh Evan
Evan right right right let me get his
name I can't remember his last name I
feel bad about that but I do remember
Gonzalo lra who was in
Ukraine Evan uh gershkovich Wall Street
Journal reporter Wall Street Journal may
be uh not
necessarily like populist right but
they're not far left and so they've got
a reporter currently detained in Russia
if Tucker Carlson presses Putin on this
reporter and why he's being held or even
gets him released and returned then that
that will be seen as a tremendous peace
effort and substantially more legitimate
however I think the interview probably
already happened so at this point you
know we we will see what this what this
becomes I bet he's back in America
before he or he was back in the US
before he put that stuff out well people
are people in public saw him so they
knew he was there when he was there yeah
I mean let's be real the state
department knew he was there before he
went oh
yeah but I think this would be uh
this is Wall Street journal's Evan
gershkovich detained in Russia in March
2023 this reporter was arrested in
Russia while on a reporting trip and uh
many people have been calling for his
release this has been it's been almost a
year now and so I don't know the
circumstances I really don't and there
are challenges to that because what was
he doing who was he in contact with for
all we know this guy was actually trying
to assist Ukraine or whatever but if
Tucker presses him on issues like this
it'll be seen as more than just
commentary my concern is that Tucker's
interview will end up just being like so
what do you think about this so what do
you think about that and then Putin just
says oh this oh that it's like we knew
those opinions already yeah think oh
sorry I no I was going to say I think
it's CRA like they're going to try and
justop is for him to humanize him at all
because a lot of people a lot of Tuckers
um like his interviews in general
humanize people a lot I think that's
like the one thing they don't want to
have happen at all like they can't stand
for this person they personally been
trying to make Hitler be humanized you
know yeah so uh Natalie F danelian says
just checking in on the left and they're
not okay so here's a funny image it's uh
Tucker Carlson wearing a Russian hat do
you know what's really funny about this
image it looks like George Bush Jr no uh
it was that everyone's favorite press
secretary had a similar hat s j saki
that's right she had her pink little
Kami hat and their Tucker never wore
that she did y these people are insane
Chattanooga Times Free Press here's one
the newest Soviet hero and there's uh
Tucker but I think some of these are old
I think they're just you know Russian
dressing haha and and Tucker is putting
on a they cannot me these are definitely
old because it says Fox on the
microphone he hasn't been there for some
time Swanson turkey Carlson Frozen
Frozen Russian asset like that one's not
even funny that's the internet they
don't know how to meme anyone with a
pencil can those are probably all old
though because they all have him at Fox
News and he's not there anymore more
this is great I had I've been wanting to
interview Putin for a long time I wanted
to go there with Lex Freeman a long time
ago I was like I just had a vision like
I was laying in bed like I have to do
this it has to happen because it's
similar like I think that the the the
message of why there's war has been obus
skated why I don't know how does how is
his English Putin I don't know he can
speak a little yeah uh it'd be great if
he gives the interview in English dude
it' be so good it's part of what makes
um but he can't ticulate himself as as
as um intricately in a second language
what you going say well what were you
you were you said that you were unsure
of why the war was going on I think a
lot of people don't know what the hell
is happening they're like does Putin
want to take over Europe that they think
that that's what's happening I thought
that he wanted that trade port in sasap
and they're trying to secure land
bridges like East 105 and East 97 those
freeways that go down into the Crimea
across the northern so they have to take
that land and they haven't Advanced much
further than that it doesn't look like
they want anything other than
Mediterranean Sea
access and that's not really a cast dis
spelly to throw our men and women at a a
Bo a meat grinder and the poor
ukrainians fund a meat grinder for those
people like I don't think so and really
if they want a new world order man
Russia and the United States can
collaborate and make that happen we have
a very very important uh note contextual
update on the uh the mayoras impeachment
Blake Moore off the hook Blake Moore
voted to impeach mayorcas only changed
his vote because they needed a
procedural reason to refile next week
okay so Blake Moore is in favor of
impeaching mayorcas the Republicans said
it I guess it can't be a tie we need a
reason to refile so change your vote he
said okay so apologies margerie Taylor
green tweeted that out saying the three
no votes were Mike Gallagher Tom M
clinck and Ken Buck Blake Moore is
actually helping them refile because of
the other three so in fact if anything
donate more to that guy for uh for for
for standing up so apologies more I
appreciate that yeah good on you Blake
exactly anyway uh Carlson cited numerous
interviews the corporate press is held
with Ukrainian President Vladimir zinski
describing them as fawning pep sessions
specifically designed to amplify
zelinsky's demand that the US enter more
deeply into a war in Eastern Europe and
pay for it that is not journalism it is
government propaganda of the ugliest
kind the kind that kills people actually
that actually he didn't he didn't
actually say I added that because it
should have been there anyway but uh
he's right he's right and I and I do I
mean look I look at what's going on
going on out politically and I really do
feel like we have a strong opportunity
to end this war machine at least in some
capacity Trump's far from perfect but
shout out to Dave Smith when he came on
the show and even he was like I yes like
Trump was way better than these other
presidents on foreign policy like and we
and we we like those things like it's
not we don't like what he did we like
the things he didn't do that every other
president did and I'm like we're winning
the Libertarians we're getting some of
them and that's good enough now with
moves like this they cannot silence us I
don't want to go to war Vladimir Putin
invading Ukraine has nothing to do with
me or you or anyone in the United States
it is garbage nonsense and that's it we
don't care about any of these other
conflicts around the world some some
country invad some other country and and
and what do we say nothing but when the
US is trying to invade and do these
things did you hear what Chuck Chuck
Schumer said the other day when he was
saying that like we may be at war in
eastern he said if we lose this war and
I said excuse me we lose this War I
didn't realize you thought we were in it
I mean I've been saying it's us many of
those who aren't stupid knew it was us
but now you have the gall to publicly
State we are fighting this war Chuck
Schumer just said on TV the US is at war
with
Russia well that's insane bulldo DC
my and the war machine I like the sound
of that except my concern is liberal
economic order is has the war machine
it's the military industrial complex
Boeing you know locki these big
Contracting comp corporations if it
transitions to a New World Order that's
like more of a corporate governance are
they going to own the war machine then
is it going to be corporations that own
lock heat and Boeing
and instead of them being subservient to
the American government they're already
owned by corporations they're f with the
US government but are they going to like
disperse SP with the US government and
then go to some corporate fascist
collusion and then it'll be like
governed from Switzerland and we'll just
become Global surfs to this corporate
monster I'm not sure what you're talking
about the new world order that want
corporatize governance I understand that
but I'm not I don't I'm not
understanding the actual structure
you're talking about or trying my
concern is that right now the American
government is sort of in control of the
of the war machine or the war machine's
in control of the American government
but they have a collusive state of being
and we're benefiting from that as
Americans in a way in a big big big way
a lot of other people are suffering
tremendously as a result so if they
transition that and it's no longer the
American government that is tied up with
this war machine would it then just be
corporations that are totally in control
no free speech anywhere they wanted to
be a lot more like China yeah so then in
that if that's the case i' I'd rather
not shut down the liberal economic order
I mean maybe I know the world wants that
and I don't like 700 American military
bases all over Earth and bombing trade
routes and and waterways and to keep
keep American Steel flowing but like the
I see two paths I see technocratic
fascism or or like militaristic fascism
I don't know what's if there's a third
way I'd like to I'd like to see it
that's my problem you don't see a third
way either like it be decentralized
governance of some sort no there's no
there's no perfect system yeah there's
just at look Communism works perfectly
and this is a fact that it's time
everyone recognized it works perfectly
after you kill anyone who dare oppose
you that's the issue when when when when
everyone is ideologically homogenized
your system works because everyone
expects what they get if you're starving
to death that's the world we live in
like Harry Tubman said I freed many
slaves I would have freed many more only
they knew they were slaves so whatever
system you have if you eliminate descent
the system operates is it the best
system well it depends on what your
definition of best is so if you look at
um parliamentary governance Democratic U
uh in you know constitutional republics
or whatever I think what we have in the
United States is the best we can come up
with but you will still get power
coalescing which leads to corruption
that needs to be accounted for and held
accountable but so long as everyone
agrees ideologically government
governance is it doesn't matter if
everyone on the planet was as religious
as Sheamus cogin you'd have World Peace
you would have no conflict no crisis
there would be no war because they would
all be ideologically homogenized it's
not because Sheamus is the nicest person
in the world or because his religion is
correct he may argue that but it's
because they all completely agree on
their moral structures and Foundations
as to what they should or should not do
which means no one would steal no one
would murder if someone did they would
all agree like that was a mistake even
the person who like I can't believe I
did it you're right I was wrong the
problem is when people disagree on what
they should be allowed to do and we're
trying to find that
balance yeah had resource
distribution um right but if everyone
was ideologically homogenized resource
distribution would not be an issue they
would all completely agree someone would
say well we need food in this city
unfortunately the only food available is
by those people and they've grown it
themselves and they're going to keep it
understood it's theirs there that's it
the the issue is there are people who
believe I I should be allowed to steal
from you because I'm more important than
you and then there's a guy who says I
grew this food it's mine you can't take
it from me I will defend it by force
because I don't want to die yeah there's
the people of like kindness and
compassion are the basis of reality and
then there's the people that are like
might makes right and those are the
people that tend to run things envious
now to be fair what I'm saying only
works with a moral Foundation if there
were people with no morals they could
all completely agree it's Myra to take
it and you get nothing but chaos War
famine you know Murder I'm I'm talking
about I I think it's fair to say like
Christianity if people followed those
tenants the way like again shout to
Sheamus kogin the way he does Faithfully
executing these these beliefs and these
good morals then the there'd be World
Peace at least for a time you you that's
until people start to develop counter
morals and then fight sure it's entirely
possible that uh you know what I'm going
to say this it it is completely factual
for a time is the correct response the
United States was a Christian Nation it
had some bad things in it worked towards
improving was very tolerant of evil let
the marxists come into their
institutions and now Christianity is
being purged yeah that's true what do
you guys think is like the best or like
the least what's the offramp Phil what's
the best path forward because if we
don't want the liberal economic Order
anymore why because it's the military
bases all over Earth are suppressing and
annihilating our neighbors and causing
massive hatred and blowback towards
American citizens I don't believe I
reject the idea that the liberal
economic order needs military bases all
over the world I think that the military
bases all over the world are simply or
are not simply but are mostly there to
deter the expansion of nuclear weapons
and I think that the whether or not you
you think that's the right thing to do
or not that's what I believe the
military bases are all over the world
for it was the the US saying look will
put you a military base in your country
that way if anyone invades your country
they risk harming the United States and
we have nuclear weapons so that means
you don't need nuclear weapons that's
the whole post World War II World Order
is is that order there is there was the
Warsaw Pact which were the Russians and
then there was the United States and
NATO and the US was like look we don't
want to have every country in NATO to
have their own nucle nuclear Arsenal so
we will put nuclear weapons in these
countries that are likely to be overrun
in Europe should the Russians decide
that they're or should the Warsaw pack
decide that they're going to run tanks
over Poland and it prevented World War
III massive stability relative stability
on Earth of Nations I me what's that
prevented it seems to have prevented
World War II as we no Total War
prevented a nuclear exchange when the
Soviet existed so maybe it's better that
we don't create a new world order that
we just keep the liberal economic order
and tell people you know get get used to
the American military bases but if
there's a communist if there's a a
Russian military base in Florida I'd be
pretty nervous but we just talked we
just literally we literally just said
that the military bases don't have
anything to do with the liberal economic
order military bases have to do with the
fact that they that we don't want
nuclear prolifer proliferation but it's
also like and buy our oil and US Dollars
by the way if you want this deal as well
well not not necessarily because because
the you there are other reasons to have
the US dollar part of the reason why we
do like foreign aid right and I'm
against all foreign aid right but part
of the reason we do it is so that way
other countries have dollars so that way
they'll spend the dollars which also
gives value to the dollar the value of
the dollar comes from the fact that
there's a demand for taxes it does come
from the fact that we have a strong
military and we can we can use military
force but it comes from a bunch of
different places now granted none of
those places are backed by anything of
value but it doesn't mean that like the
the liberal economic order is in is
inherently connected with military bases
all over the us or all over the world
have you guys seen the line I have in
Saudi Arabia yeah oh yeah yeah they
started building it oh they did start it
yep we should pull up a video of this
crazy this is wild building well the
thing about is like follows like their
their regular population path actually
is along that line anyway so they're
really like just like consolidating and
making into a a 50 minute city is it
like along a river or something no no
it's no no it just it just connects if
you look at the way Saudi Arabia is like
along the one coast and then across
across the whole country they have
another one right there they're building
a linear City that much different
reports give it different lengths I've
heard 110 miles 105 miles and 75 miles
but the idea is it's a 500 meter tall 75
to 100 mile long
skyscraper that will have I believe
underground uh Transit that shoots back
and forth and can get to the from end to
end in 20 minutes wow yeah so travel 75
miles in 20 minutes somebody I think
might have been Mike cernovich somebody
really funny tweeted out they were like
well this is a border wall so whoever's
going to be living there prepare to
defend your wall I was like okay but
it's in the middle of the desert but he
actually trenched it out I think this
will be elisium like you ever SE the
movie
elesium if you watch the video for this
they talk about how it'll be this look
at this like mirror walled skyscraper
City yeah it's one big skyscraper and
they said the re one of the purposes of
having it be the line is that you can
exit you can get to any point within it
and easily walk out into nature and back
but I think and they they also mention
it is being strategically placed within
6 hours of the world oh that's creepy
air travel interesting can you leave the
wall that anywhere you are like a wall
you can fly there within six hours it's
not really I mean obviously in in in the
in the eastern hemisphere
so they're like everywhere around we'll
have like a 6our path to arrival and
it's being built in Saudi Arabia correct
yep right across it and they've started
building it that's I did not think they
actually do it and they've already got
like construction they've made small
cities yeah for just construction it's
like temporary housing where the
construction workers live and the
materials are housed and they've started
trenching out this is what this is what
the image look at this yeah look at how
much earth that is they started
trenching out to build the foundation of
this I wonder how far across it is or
how wide it is uh they say but uh you
can actually you can actually look at
the truck and then you know it's pretty
big it's it's it's pretty big this is
like a wonder of the world I mean a lot
of them come
from part of me is excited that
someone's actually trying to do
something grandiose like it'll be
remembered in hundreds of thousands of
years if it stands yeah like the
wreckage of this would remain for tens
of thousands like all the pictures and
stuff if it works and it and it turns
out the way that that it could and of
the places where it might Saudi Arabia
does have the the proper government
structure to be like all right we're
just going to make this happen The King
The King said do it and we've got enough
money to throw at it so like never
ending money the reason I brought this
up is we're talking about like the New
World Order and stuff yep like I feel
like this will be the Multicultural
Global globalist City part of the plan
is to get uh a lot of humans away from
nature into mega cities into a giant
desert like where you will live in a big
tube which is so reliant on the outside
for resources man if they get cut off
from the outside that's like where do
you run how do you get out of there
they're going to have probably vertical
Farms every certain
distance and then you can exit but it
doesn't matter it's it's the it's it's
you know based on what they were saying
about it the fact they're building it I
I wouldn't be surprised if in a 100
years it's where all of like the
powerful Global Elites live the
politician for your country won't live
in your country he'll live in the line
he'll have a massive you know penthouse
suite up there there was somewhere a
thing in Sim City called The archology I
used to play those games a lot Sim City
2000 or something where there's like
just a standalone ecosystem kind of like
biodome I thought they were so awesome
because you can build them on Mars you
can build them underground you can build
them on the moon like self-contained
ecosystems but then now the threat of
like if they get cut off from the
outside and then the people like if
you've seen biodome you know love movie
didn't go so well for the guys in the
biodome I don't think they just smoked a
lot of weed or something I don't
remember I saw fly sure they weren't
supposed to be in it they got lost oh
they snuck into the biodome there was a
party or something and they went in and
then I think what they they're trying to
go to the bathroom oh they they started
building this a year and a half ago did
they really want W yeah in November what
about but like the actual trenching I
assumed it would just fizzle out huh
isn't neom supposed to be their other
that's this is neon yeah I'm pretty sure
that's the name okay all right this is
part of it yeah
okay the name of the city they yeah
that's what they want to be their like
uh
modern thing the their modern city that
was the project dude this looks like
Destiny have you guys ever played uh
Destiny no when you go to the Vex it
looks like this yes yeah it's
creepy nessus that that reminds me of
nessus the the planet the nessus planet
I love that stff play video to discover
the
line for too long Humanity has existed
with dysfunctional and polluted cities
that ignore nature now a revolution in
Civilization Tak
Place imagine a traditional City and
consolidating its footprint designing to
protect and enhance nature the line will
be home to 9 million residents and will
be built with a footprint of just 34
Square km I just want to point out what
you just watched they took everyone's
homes CR mashed them together and then
put walls around them
like prison literally just put you in
jail sustainable quality of life so
creepy the Lion's communities are
organized in three dimensions three
classes right residents have access to
all their daily needs within 5 minute
walk neighborhoods 5 minute City 5
minute City you never have where we
getting sold a 15minute city I want a 5
minute City I we got to build our own
line right and the line's infrastructure
makes it possible to travel end to end
in 20 minutes with no need for cars
resulting in zero carbon
emissions that's another thing by
Levering AI technology services are
autonomous saving you time and
effort designed by World leading
Architects the line is 500 M
tall 200 M wide wow 170 km long and
housed within an elegant mirror glass
facade intelligent solution who are
going to shoot the hell out of this
thing this thing right I didn't know it
was south of Jordan on the it's e it's
east of egpt it's west of oh they're
dead wait they the map designed as a
series of unique communities offering a
wealth of amenities providing Equitable
views and immediate access to the
surrounding nature that it's 40% of the
world accessible within 6 hours okay
there we go 40% of the world so creepy
accessible in 6 hours at the heart of
the globe's key trade routes a place for
Commerce and communities to thrive that
Sinai right there yeah that's it's liter
the houthis are going to start shooting
missiles as soon as the Israelis do
something that piss off the houthis look
out they're just going to start shooting
missiles then maybe there's going to be
a World War II they're going to flatten
all the opposition and then build their
build their
lineen
they literally they literally call it
they literally call it a new wonder of
the world is dumb
new that's that's uh Saudi Arabia and
that's like where Oman and Y is yeah
that's the name of the company the lion
it look if you look at how the walls
built right up to the Gulf of aaba is
that what it's called Gulf of aaba yeah
it looks like a border wall like it
looks like they're trying to defend the
Gulf of aaba with this
thing to
protect is a really idea just going to
which works for isra and Jordan shipping
things South and Egypt through I got be
honest I'm I don't care because it's not
America foreign country wants to do it
don't care I'd actually love to visit
except for the Saudi Arabia thing they
kind of put women in prison after
getting raped so it's not a it's not not
really a country I'd ever like to go do
they cut heads and hands off man in the
Middle East you can get your head cut
off for for witchcraft L like literally
a dude got his head a cut off like in
the past 5 years for witchcraft it's a
lot of propaganda zuie live from there
he lived there he he'll tell you it's a
lot of Western propaganda to fear-monger
us from going over there and
experiencing the world I don't know man
I saw I saw the court case you know
they're like look this guy this guy was
practicing witchcraft there are women
who got raped and then when they report
the rape they go to jail for uh having
sex out of marriage adultery yeah yeah
women women only recently got the you
know the right to drive cars
yeah well very controversial mean that
was a big mistake women need to be
driving car two steps for two steps
forward one step back two steps forward
one step back so but maybe it becomes
the uh
Multicultural Mecca
ha you know it's actually fairly close
to Medina yeah it is I mean but and it
to me it just it look man that is just
begging for some pissed-off radical to
blow just fly something into it yeah
drones airplanes Miss Rockets whatever
it'd be cool to go shopping there I mean
yes it would I would love to I want to
see the under transit system right like
tunnel under 20 minutes to travel 75
miles in a highspeed train underground
or whatever I'm excited like I really
hope they finish it fairly soon like I
hope it doesn't take like 50 years to
finish it because I would like to see
what it looks like hope they can knock
that 20 minutes on 15 minutes though
then I really have sold I mean I mean
uh I think
theoretically what two decades what do
you think maybe what's their time frame
for this well again it's Saudi Arabia
they got money and authoritarian that's
what I'm saying this isn't like be like
do it tomorrow a government contract
this is the prince of a Nation with tons
of oil being like we're making it happen
now yeah I have unlimited money we're
going to do this true it will not look
this nice the slums will be amazing oh
the smell yeah oh dude it's going to be
like cyberp it's going to be like all
these nightmare dystopias you see how
they these pictures where look how
beautiful it will be no dude you have no
idea pig iron and it's going to be AI
will protect you then the lights go out
and like where's the AI why is fixing
the lights it is always GNA come down to
there are poor people Y and maybe it's
possible that if your income drops below
a certain threshold or whatever they
just boot you out by force for real
because otherwise what happens is
someone's going to be like I can pay my
rent my my line fee or I can clean and
they're not going to clean I mean you
can't do anything about it and people do
drugs even rich people think of all the
hunter bidens who are going to be there
and also the is I mean maybe not
isolation but the the lack of Freedom
like Freedom meaning the ability to go
where you want to go to spread out you
know you're free to move around that
lack of Freedom could cause people to go
inside what would Manhattan look like
with the line oh no should we play it oh
yes they're going to show it all green
and Lush yeah we got to watch
this reimagining New York see that okay
I'm sorry that's
hell this is so
creepy this doesn't make any sense
cramming 2.5 million people in Manhattan
into a single line why would you do that
and then and then putting a wall around
them progress they they would do that
because they believe they control your
carbon the idea is getting rid of
streets compresses everything it would
be nice to get rid of streets and just
have tunnels if they work I don't want
to live in a prison though it wouldn't
like if you could just walk down some
stairs and shoot to your destination
hold on and there's all grass up up you
never to look both ways when you leave
your house just grass and fruit and
and there's there's no prisons they just
kick you
out yeah they say you're convicted they
walk out open the door be like have fun
let the Bears take care of into the
desert I've never been to the desert
before don't throw me out there well in
New York yeah in New York you just let
the black the Bears future of urban
living this is it I when I'm studying
agenda 2030 they talk about mega cities
it's it's really a fascinating concept
but that that the humans have done so
much damage to Nature they want to kind
of get them away and let let things Rew
on their own they're the pr the the
presupposition in that statement is that
humans actually have damaged nature and
I reject that entirely like the idea
that humans have damaged that you can
damage nature like I don't think that
you can damage nature like the like what
is nature nature is like the naturally
occurring world what is how what is
damaging it changing it I don't believe
like the the the the the impulse that
comes from like environmentalists that
any human impact is negative and
damaging like guys I don't I don't buy
it it's only $200 billion it's basically
it's basically one Ukraine I will write
a check it's it's it's oh yeah for the
cost of Ukraine uh National Defense one
country you can get one weird long line
City if I was in Congress I'd be like I
would like to divert all future funding
from Ukraine into building the align a
us we'll do it in the middle of the
country we'll we'll create tons of
American jobs to build biggest
straw
and I don't know when I'm trying to find
out when they think it's going to be
done yeah me too check this out they say
by March 2023 more than 4,500 piles had
been driven into module 43 60 piles per
day piling shifted to 45 46 47 so I mean
it's coming yeah I I thought it was fake
but
uh what's the what's the timeline for
this thing 2030 no no no no no no no
wait wait wait no way by uh it will
boost their GDP by 2030 is what just the
work it's like a work program oh okay
and I I wouldn't be surprised if they
open part of it early when like the
first you know right 20% of it's been
built and it's kind of like the Death
Star like it's fully operational line
yeah wouldn't I mean I imagine they
would want to be like look it's a
working you know the the the concept
works this the five minute cities people
are living here and they're happy and
blah blah blah so I imagine that they'll
probably want it to be open at ASAP I'd
love the visit this place just the
concept of centralizing humanity is it
will be it will be the densest city on
Earth yeah 26,000 people per square
kilometer Manila the world's most
densely populated city is 44,000 smells
like it I don't think so with walls
around it it's walled City it's the
densest city on earth and it's walled I
mean you used to need walls when there
were Siege cannons and stuff but now
they have air power you don't really
walls don't really do as much it's part
of their Vision 2030 project oh wow
agenda 2030 I wonder what's going to
happen in the next few years as we get
close to 2030 I think what's going to
happen is within the next 16 years we're
going to have an American president tell
us to to do this Manhattan wall they're
going to start pushing this concept
so45 they say total completion but it's
it's I think Ian's right they're going
to roll out modules of it so like when
module one opens they'll probably start
bringing in they they have to do it they
can't build the whole thing and then
bring in 9 million people so there will
be people who have already lived there
for probably 5 or 10 years when the
final
you know construction is done and then
there'll be some big crazy party I'd
love to go there so what are we looking
at we're looking at 21 years 21 years
until it's done I won't even be retired
by then so perfect now you still be
working yeah exactly all right we're
going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.net
friends you will also get to get tickets
to our upcoming live event in
Martinsburg West Virginia at the cast
Brew location C Brew is not open yet
won't be open for some time second floor
however is a private club for members so
if you're a member and you want to hang
out at our private club you got to sign
up and then when the tickets become
available you can buy them and then uh
we're working out how we're handling the
actual private club in Martinsburg
because it will be like if you're a
timcast member you'll have access but
it's probably going to be a tiered thing
where I don't know what it might be it
might be a hundred bucks a month for you
like uh um what's first come first serve
access so basically our view of it was
to compete with the high-end clubs they
do in places like New York where they're
$50,000 a year and this one would be
like a 100 bucks a month which basically
covers the cost of food which will be
you know food and drinks are available
certain like better foods that might you
know higher end dinners and stuff you
might actually have to pay for but it
would pay for the security staff the
doors and then there would be event
where any member could buy a ticket to
we're not completely sure how it's going
to operate yet but as a member when we
put up the ticket sales which will be
maybe in a couple weeks that will be for
the the event we're probably only going
to have 50 tickets so you're definitely
going to want to be a member so that you
can see right when they come up and you
can buy them but uh let's read some
super chats for now smash that like
button and Richard Bowski says not first
you are in fact first nice job dude
Christopher Lambert says cheating my way
to First unfortunately you were second
unfortunately Cory Anderson Cory
Anderson says down goes ra down goes ra
yeah absolutely kale says hey Tim I made
a cold brew using rise with Roberto Jr
and enjoyed it so much I threw it on the
menu at Chronic Golf Plus games on
Hilton Head is that South Carolina we're
we're proud to be found on Public Square
our big timcast fans well boy do I have
news for you wholesale pricing I believe
is rolling out I don't know if it's
available now uh we have somebody who
runs Casper we have a staff member who's
taking care of it but um wholesale
pricing is uh going to save you a pretty
penny and then uh we'll we'll figure
that one out I don't know much about it
right now but it's good news for you if
you want to get to cheaper prices for
your for your uh
wholesaling let's go Direction says
could I get a culture War shout out for
a Kickstarter called animating cradle
it's an anti-woke series with classical
values that DC's Jay Oliva wants to make
into an animated series Tim would enjoy
it perhaps well there you go best of
luck good sir
all right chako says Tim Matt Gates and
Al stonic introduced a resolution to say
that Trump did not incite an
Insurrection we talking about it we're
talking about it now that's right uh he
did and so if they all vote on it then
there you go it's it's assessed and
asserted let's grab some more Super
chats let's find a good one Jason
Hutchinson says Disney reaping what they
have sowed where's the popcorn this is
going to be fun to watch
I saw the Marvels okay I saw I saw the
Marvels I saw 60% of the Marvels oh no I
could I I had to stop really it is the
worst it's one of the worst movies I've
ever seen oh man yeah I couldn't do it
it
is I would describe it Like Home Alone 3
je it's horrible horrible description of
a movie no I haven't seen any of that it
sounds terrible want to yeah watch Home
Alone 3 at least you'll enjoy yourself
oh wow it was so bad the mar made no
sense the storyline is dejected it's
choppy they just crammed a bunch of
garbage together and said we fulfilled
our contractual obligations have a nice
day really really
dumb yep very dumb so sad but good luck
Disney Kieran the meat man says hey Tim
please shout out billong Baron on Public
Square there's also a timcast exclusive
discount in the Discord
give me your money so I can advertise
more on Public Square sounds great we
love Public Square uh and shout out to
Beaver Fleming I had made a comment on
the show about I I saw someone at Nitro
Circus sponsored by Public Square and uh
I did not realize it was Beaver he's uh
an amazing skateboard does back flips
and all this other crazy stuff and he is
sponsored by Public Square that is like
the coolest thing ever shout out to
Public Square and beaver Fleming awesome
I'm so glad to see Public Square
sponsoring getting involved in the
cultural stuff massive absolutely
amazing we're going to
win let's go uh rusta zero says favro
really liked Gina actually was going to
make her the star of Rangers of the new
Republic but then uh KK had her gone
yeah Katherine what's her name Kennedy
Kath Kennedy Kathleen Kennedy is that is
mean well the issue was that Gina wasn't
gay yeah we all saw South Park she was
not lame either
yeah let let's uh get some more here
we'll find some more Super chats Jason
Dixon says Tim the FBI just arrested a
Maga sniper who was trying to kill
illegal immigrants it feels like another
Governor Whitmer fed op it was this guy
was talking to a uce on Tik Tock they
now have undercover FBI agents dming
people on Tik Tok so he he befriended a
federal agent and sold them some kind of
suppressor for a gun or something and
then talked to them about his ideas and
that's what he's being charged with like
running his mouth they're desperately
trying to make it happen they need it so
bad oh they're not getting it they're
calling him like a militia person I
don't think there's any evidence he was
in a militia other than him wanting to
be ELO Lopez says thank you Tim for
reminding and inspiring everyone to
create content that doesn't hate America
I made over 100 books 25 on American
values 50 books on America's awesome
animals on Amazon because of uh because
of print on demand God Bless Texas and
America I want to know the name of that
stuff where do we find you on Amazon
yeah how we got to find it Eloy Lopez
curiel well good luck I hope people buy
your
books Let's Go Philip breed says bu cast
Brew don't delay act now supplies are
running out allow if you're still alive
6 to8 days to arrive and if you follow
there may be a tomorrow but if the offer
is shunned you might as well be walking
on the sun I know the guy that wrote
that song he was actually here he played
he has a great that's Greg Camp shout
out to Greg camp with Smashmouth and now
uh the defant yes and he was here and it
was crazy cuz I didn't know a lot about
him but then they were like oh yeah he
wrote Allstar and walking on the sun I
was like no that's crazy dude super
chill he has the same birthday as me too
April 2 look at that shout out to Greg
Camp let's go Brett tesdall says don't
know if you saw an X Roseanne Bar
reached out to Elon Musk regarding the
Disney lawsuit game
on man this is in regards to the Conor
Rosanne that got she got fired from R
show was that an ABC show now they they
just killed Roseanne they just
slaughtered her on the show they they
they just one day they came like the
show came on and they were like Roseanne
died of an overdose while sleeping or
like while while you were all sleeping
it's like oh that's it moving on wow
such an awful thing to do for her
politics what did she do she took
ambient and then tweeted at somebody
anti-semitic slur something not even
close I don't remember okay wasn't even
she tweeted a photo of the Planet of the
Apes Apes character at Valerie Jared oh
that's right right in said and they said
that she was racist and she was like
what do you mean racist she just looks
like that lady and like yeah but she's
black and she's like I don't understand
and they were like you compared a black
woman to a Planet of the Apes character
and she's like I didn't mean it like
that and they're like you're
fired she's like I thought she was white
yeah I thought she was
white she really but like it's kind of
ridiculous that when so we had um you
know Alex Jones came on the show and
kept saying I am a gorilla because of
because of that book ishmail and so we
we made the meme like we haven't really
it's it's it's been a long time but we
had the shirts and it's the gorilla
going I am a gorilla and then people
were calling us racists for having a
shirt that says I am a gorilla what and
I was like I was like my dude it is an
ishmail reference we are making a
reference to Global policy not race if
you think that's racist what are you
thinking about people take it up with
Daniel Quinn writer yo I don't know if
yall remember this some of the prints
that were
sold yo I think this was intentional
some of the prints that were made of it
had the gorilla wearing white gloves
with a blackened face yep and someone
posted a picture being like why did my
t-shirt come like this and we reached
out to Teespring which is the company
that does the the distribution and we
were like yo what the this is like we
made a gorilla thing which is just like
it's like I am gorilla like it's it's
about ishmail it's about being tough or
whatever there's the gorilla emojis
and there were some people receiving
shirts where I'm like how do you
accidentally make the hands look like
white gloves yeah I don't believe it I
was like I think somebody who worked
with these companies knew and they and
they changed it intentionally because
it's not Teespring Teespring just
contracts like there will be a a print
shop oh yep Teespring and so Teespring
was really cool about it they apologized
and they're like we'll get it sorted no
no no worries and uh mad respect to them
they we still sell merch through them
and everything's been great and so they
were pissed too and it was apparently
like one print shop somewhere was making
these shirts and uh so if you have one I
mean at some point I guess it might be
worth a lot of money it's the blackface
gorilla timcast shirt yeah crazy right
dude it's so wild that ishmail that
whole book of ishmail I read it in like
2007 and I I was buying into all of it
now the way Alex was like the book's
telling you like the gorilla's like uh
humans are bad I'm a bad I'm a gorilla
kill like he's like it's about like
you're so bad being a human like what
you've done to the Earth you're a taker
there are takers and there are levers
and we've out the takers have
outbalanced the levers and we need more
levers on Earth I get that concept you
know but it's it's interesting to think
about it that I was manipulated by by
this book yeah great it was awesome book
really awesome Frontline Texon says Tim
you're absolutely correct about Maga
being a different party and using a
different animal logo they
unintentionally did a genius move and
began copying L leninist tactics lenon
is quoted as saying if you cannot make
the party capture the party yes
interesting yeah
all right up Bish says I live in
California District 48 after that
comment I'm likely voting for Isa
LOL well again uh Blake Moore did good
yeah I saw the uh here we go yeah uh x
10 man says Moore switched his vote from
yes to no so they could reconvene so
shout out to Moore and uh I hope I hope
that correction goes far and wide
because he did a good thing and so he
earns extra brownie points for that one
that's right Ken Buck is way more than a
Democrat look up his ties he's a classic
big government
spook well there you go that's from 2A
Willie Lurch says all of that cheering
sounded awfully
female well there you go and then he
says repeal the
19th all the what cheering at when they
when they didn't impeach mayorcas oh I
hope people realize that imp like repeal
the 19th as a meme is like it's it'll
get a chuckle you're not going to win
any if that's your actual platform
you're going to lose because women will
vote against you exactly but I how about
only net taxpayers can vote I mean look
any anything as much as I like the idea
of like having people that have a stake
in the society voting or being limited
to vote or only those people being able
to vote you're never going to convince
people even people that the law would
not affect you're never going to
convince people that it's a good idea to
limit people's ability to vote even if
you could manage to prove that it would
produce better results people are still
going to have that knee-jerk gut
reaction that it's bad to take away
people's right to vote because this is
the I mean you don't you no no sane
politician ever going to go and say like
hey we want to take away your right to
vote what you say is the voting
enhancement act will protect the
sanctity of democracy you like voting
right and you like the system we want to
protect it so let's stand up against
these bullies who are trying to damage
this country and and defend the voter
enhancement act yeah it would have to be
something like that but if you're your
average person understood oh I love that
Meme have you seen that Meme where it's
like a politician they're like I'd like
to propose the free sodas for all act
will you pass it yes yay it's passed
person goes now where's my free soda
free soda this bill bans owning a dog ex
it's real close yeah all right Jason
Dixon says Tim call for Scott Pressler
as RNC chairperson that would be amazing
I don't know if anyone's more effective
than he is oh he'd be great great but
they're not going to do it because even
even Trump is still an Old Guard he is
probably yeah people like him better
than the uni party but Trump is
still he's still going to be going to
like he wants to own the Republican
party you know so they are loyalist in
the Republican Party who are agreeing
with him but if we really want a Maga
replacement
I gotta be honest that's that's beyond
the Trump era that's like yeah that's
2032 you know that's a v ramas Swami
starts firing people the what Trump did
was capture a you know an um an emotion
that is kind of going on in America but
he doesn't know why or how he just knows
that he did everything with Trump is gut
instinct he has absolutely no idea what
he's doing he's going by gut and it just
so happens that he's got a great gut
instinct Linda Welker says Blake Mo of
changed vote to no for procedural reason
he is not against impeachment it keeps
it open until next week and I wanted to
read that one just to make sure we can
hammer it as much as possible because I
don't want anyone anyone negatively
impacted because of a contextual error
on our part so shout out to Blake Moore
for doing the good work and he gets he
gets double points everyone who voted no
who or who voted yes to impeach meus
that's good he changed his vote to help
keep alive after the Republicans were
betrayed then he gets two browny points
out of one good stuff I've got to say
though if the votes tie you should be
able to do it again next week you
shouldn't have to lose to do it again a
ties yeah I don't know what the I don't
know how that works though like I don't
know why that procedural reason was you
know I don't know yeah but I'm glad he
did it so shout out shout
out let's go Maxa says we lift the ban
the boycott when they apologize and meet
the demands of workers threatening to go
on strike
I don't know what's he talking about
anheiser Bush oh yes okay that's it
yep let's see what we got tway willly
says you can tell that the Trump family
knows the Budweiser people go back and
watch Don Jr's stuff we do need to get
them to apologize uh I BL every day
before drank Bud Light before I don't
think that we're I don't think there's
going to be any apology coming forward I
understand that that's what people want
but it is it is already a cold
uh topic now at this point it's been too
long since it happened I mean it started
in what June you know I don't see I I'm
telling you come April when the when the
year-to-year wraparound in sales hits
think so they're going to start
reporting no no no they're going to
report a 1% increase in sales and then
they're going to budlight will declare
Victory budlight does not have the moral
convictions you guys have they don't
care they want to win in the in the
press and they will get all of their
allies in the corporate media to
announce the boycott has failed budlight
sales are recovering and of course the
numbers won't actually be there it's
just going to be that come June when
it's year-over-year sales despite the
fact they're down 30% it will normalize
and if they sell one more beer now it's
up and then everyone in the corporate
press is going to say a year after the
boycott budlight is recovering sales are
up their stock pric is already rebounded
the boycott has failed so we need action
now and that may be forcing them to
apologize before before June I think
they're just like look guys we make it a
year we'll get the pr on our side it's
all matters oh I think they're desperate
right now to of course write the wrong
to write the ship and they're going to
have a general strike on their hands and
the company's going go that's that's
that's that's that's bad Bud Light could
go under because uh volume is everything
so uh I explained this when the strike
first happened but I'll break it down
real quick we wanted to sell cast Brew
cold brew we wanted to sell actual cans
that we could have sent to like gas
stations and and stores it would cost us
$5 per can at the amount we are capable
of
ordering because the amount of profit
you can generate is Razor thin so if I
sell 10 cans of cold brew and I make 10
cents that is not nearly enough to keep
this machine going like I I'll make the
money back for the cans but we're we're
razor thin profits but what if I sell 10
million cans that that 10 cents per 10
cans act that's that's up it adds up now
I'm making millions of dollars and then
you can start to save up and invest and
you have a this big system so for Bud
Light as they start selling less and
less and less their margins are going to
are going to be collapsing exponentially
they're not going to be able to pay
their staff which is happening the staff
will then go on strike which will make
even less Bud Light available already
people aren't buying
it and then the costs are going to be
too great to produce a can of beer and
they're going to say we go micro brew or
we stop production of this failed brand
so I don't know when that could happen
that could happen in April and for the
record Donald Trump Jr did demand well
Daily Mail says he demanded it but he
apparently wanted to end the boycott in
y April of
2023 which was April bizarre that was
when it started April 14th it started 10
days before that really yeah wow okay it
was like April 7th wasn't it it was on
his trigger chose April 1st interesting
April they did it on April 1st wow they
should have just said like April fools
on you yeah they should have it was a
joke didn't you get the
joke let's go Daniel chenowth says
apology plus James and Shawn for a
two-minute voice on their belief who's
Shawn oh Strickland Sean Strickland oh
yeah yeah that'd be
great all
right Ox Lauren says if someone told you
men are women then a year later they
tell you they changed their mind would
you seriously believe leave them inbev
is officially out Bev for
Life
yep Shan L says Tim this is the Late
Night show my kids will grow up
listening to I'm asking everyone for
prayers for my wife she's 34 weeks with
twins Ezekiel and Evelyn she has severe
preclampsia please pray for her health
Sean I I hope for the best I pray for
the best best of luck to you and best
health and I hope everyone does send
there prayers and and best wishes yes I
will pray as well healing what is
preclampsia
I mean I've heard of it idea find out
don't enough about
it preclampsia did you find it I had a
wonderful pregnancy I had no
issues it's a according to Wikipedia
serious complication of pregnancy that
can occur after the 20th week or after
giving birth characterized by high blood
pressure
protina another signs of organ damage
high blood pressure breathe out breathe
out the hot air out of your mouth that's
the carbon dioxide it adds an electron
onto it you control your body pressure
and hence your your blood pressure it's
really cool so just focus on your breath
and breathing out that hot air you'll be
okay a apron says disagree with
demanding an apology from Bud Light Tim
you and the crew have always encouraged
people don't apologize to the woke mob
wouldn't a demand by boycotters a mob be
nearly the same no um because they're
evil and we're good that's it I'm not
going to ex no no explanations um we're
just righteous and therefore everything
we do is good no I will get into it
they're lying they're lying about what
they actually believe to manipulate you
we want budlight to to reject those who
are lying and trying to destroy and
subvert this country the people on the
right take a look at the mayus
impeachment these Republicans are so I
have to be honorable and compromise it's
the right thing to do and then they get
steamrolled for it and the left just
says we'll burn everything down they
burn down police stations and don't go
don't go to jail for it now actually a
guy did get convicted for burning on a
police station and and I think it was in
during the George Floyd ride so that
does happen I'm not saying it doesn't
but they they will they will stand in
Congress in lock step for the most
insane policies AOC siding with Nancy
Peli in an instant they don't they
they're whipped into shape so when we
say budlight apologize it's because we
need them to reject the horrifying
Marxist garbage and we need a public
acceptance of that when you apologize to
woke mob they weaponize it against you
they say aha we got you you proved it
now we own you if budlight apologizes to
us we say okay we'll buy your beer from
you again and give you money totally
totally different
all right everybody if you haven't
already please would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show really take the
URL post it where every everywhere you
can it's one of the best ways you can
help out if you're not a member or or
not buying cash per coffee but also
become a member by going to
timcast.net
then a lot of swearing a lot of very
offensive statements actually it's it's
much more fun it's a very different show
you should come hang out you'll get
access to the Discord server you can
hang out hang out with like-minded
individuals it's good fun and you can
even call in to talk to us and our guest
so smash that like button you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally at timcast Christina do
you want to shout anything out yes um my
documentary you can watch the trailer
for it you can support the film at KK
film.com it's the letter K cuz I didn't
want to get kidnapp and kill.com that'd
be a little weird
so K and the word K and K yep K and K
film.com
awesome I am Phil it remains on Twix I
am Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can follow us on Spotify Apple music
Amazon music Pandora YouTube you know
the internet and don't forget the left
lane is for Crime I'm Ian Crossland good
to be here good to be back good to see
you Christina always a pleasure um all
right let's let's move it on yeah uh
let's go to the after show I'm surge.com
see you there we'll see you all over at
timcast.net